resounding message that
democracy will not be killed in
the comfort of silence. Today we
send a clear message to speaker
Cameron sexton that the people
will not allow his his crimes
against democracy that happen
without challenge. The people of
Nashville have spoken today
through their council members
and democracy. We stand for the
vision of a multiracial
democracy. Democracy is our
division we're offering to this
body this building that has
forgotten it. And so we're
waiting now for the minutes from
the city council meeting, but I
want to thank everybody for
coming out the thousands of
people from across the state and
across this nation who showed up
because this is not about one
person. It's not about one
position, but it's about a
movement of people power to
restore the soul and heart of
what this building should
represent. And that is
democracy. So I want to thank
you all for being here today,
particularly the young people
who are the heartbeat of this
movement. It was students taking
walking out of classes and
taking to this capital that led
us into the well that day
calling for common sense gun
laws. And the first thing I do
when I walk into this building
as a representative is to
continue that call for common
sense gun legislation. Secondly
we are calling on house speaker
Cameron sexton to resign as
speaker of the house. He is an
enemy of democracy, and the
people have spoken and so we'll
continue to speak up and resist
and show up. Because this is the
rebirth, the resurrection of a
movement in Tennessee. That's
gonna keep going not just today
, but in the days ahead, we will
continue to show out in birth. A
new south because right here in
Nashville, we've had movements
before, led by young people that
transformed this nation and his
our time again. Together not one
step back. Just Justin. What is
this meant to you to have the
support? Justin what has his
back? This kind of support. What
does this mean to you just shows
that our movement is bigger than
one person that has thousands of
people from across the nation
and Lydia across the world who
showed up today to stand in
solidarity with the crime that
happened here in Tennessee and
people are resisting. People are
showing up. People are calling
us to act and the decision to
expel it yesterday was not. The
final decision on Thursday was
not the final decision that they
try to crucify democracy. But
you see here a resurrection of a
movement of multiracial movement
for democracy happening in
Tennessee with my brother
Pearson. Yes. Listen. Good to
see you. Great to see you again.
See this happen? Democracy
steelworks and people. Power
always wins coming up. What?
What's the joint message that
you want to send to the to the
nation right now? Who's watching
this about? Maybe not giving up
in a movement. It is never a
good idea to give up on the
movement led morally right is
never a good idea to give up on
the movement led by people that
look like this who are committed
to the ideals but not just
committed in heart but in body
and spirit, and they'll show up
for the movement. They are
protests for the movement.
They'll fight for the movement
and so to anyone who has doubted
the south. Anyone who's doubted
the power of Tennessee and
advocate for an end to gun
violence. Anybody who's doubted
the movement to end assault
weapons ban anybody who's down
the movement. Here's your answer
. The movement still lives. A
couple of things. Hello thank
you. Which one? You go on. There
you go. Inside. They brought.
That they could turn our
democracy there. Mob ocracy.
They thought that they could
turn the people's chamber and
the people's house into their
own place of pontificating of a
status quo that harms and kills
us. They thought that if they
could expel the voice of the
people that the people would not
rise. Alright they thought that
if they could kick out
representative Justin Jones that
he would never again be
representative Justin Jones. But
they were wrong. And today what
we see is that having a moral
center matters having a vision
for this state and this country
that says justice is possible
matters. Having a voice and a
vision in the statehouse that
will choose to even get expelled
in order that the vision that
each and every one of us hold
within our hearts. Of a
pluralistic, multiracial, multi
ethnic, multi multi economic
democracy might live. Is way
more powerful than the N R a or
the gun lobbyists or anybody who
told us we just need to shut up
and sit down. Because indeed
what the Nashville metro council
has done with the unanimous
decision. Brother representative
Justin Jones, back into his
calling as an elected official.
Justice will roll down like
waters and righteousness like an
ever flowing stream will happen
. You might try and silence it.
You might try and expel it, but
the people's power will not be
stopped. People power will be
stopped. People's power will not
be something because this is
what democracy looks like. Hey
wolf. You heard the powerful
words from the two members and
obviously they are wrapping up
right now. We are told, playing
right now is to go inside the
building there waiting for the
minutes from the city council.
Once I received those minutes,
then they will March toward that
capital go back inside, and
Jones plans to get his seat
back. So this is all happening
right now. I got to show you
this crowd direction as far as
the eye can see, you can see
people going all the way down
the stairs. So they plan to do a
moment of silence. I'm gonna for
them. For the mass shooting.
That happened in Louisville
today, so that's what they're
gonna mark. This moment. It's
all about gun control. Want you
to stay with us? I also want to
bring in our chief national
affairs correspondent Jeff
Zeleny, who's watching this very
, very closely, Jeff. How your
reaction first of all to what?
We just heard. Well, look, it's
extraordinary, really the speed
in which the Nashville council
unanimously sent former
representative Jones back to his
seat temporarily. This is a two
step process. He's going to have
to run for his seat again, but
wolf what it shows is that he
now is something of a hero to
the gun control movement to
youth activists, of course in
Tennessee, but indeed across the
country as well, so it really
raises the question of what was
this all for anyway? What did
the speaker of the Tennessee
house and his fellow Republicans
do last week and was that in the
best interest in their best
interest? It's certainly has not
moved forward the conversation.
About. This epidemic of gun
violence in the country in
neighboring Kentucky. We saw
again today. Of course, another
shooting. So this, of course,
the politics of this are very
important. It shows that the
youth activism is alive and well
, and this movement of people
standing up from across the
spectrum, young and old, really
pushing force the elected
officials to do something on
guns is going to continue,
regardless of what their elected
officials do in terms of decorum
or whatnot, so it really just
resumes. Perhaps the
conversation. About about two
guns, but we should be honest
here. It is unlikely that any
individual shooting will have an
impact. It's going, it's going
to take a collective movement
here, and I think that's what
we're seeing. We're seeing this
right in the middle of this,
Jeff. Stand by for a second.
Ryan, if you can hear me, I'm
anxious to get your perspective
. You're there on the scene for
us. How remarkable is it for a
state representative to be
expelled and then reinstated by
his city just a few days later.
Well, when you hear about some
of the state representatives who
weren't kicked out before for
offenses that are far greater
than the ones that happened
here, you understand why so many
people here are upset. I
remember Jeff Zeleny a few days
ago, talking about John Lewis
and how this kind of ties
together. These young men are
taking examples from John Lewis
and Dr king and they're using
them. It's one of the reasons
why they wanted to walk up John
Lewis and Dr king street on the
way up here. They are leaning
heavily on the old civil rights
movement. I can tell you as you
see everybody right now, as
they're getting ready to go in.
We were just told the minutes
from the city council have
arrived with. So now this walk
is getting ready to take place
where all these people plan to
escort the representative back
into the people's house. I don't
know if I have everything seen
anything play out like this, but
you can see this groundswell of
emotion as people started
walking this way, so we're gonna
try to catch up to the front.
That way. We can be there when
he walks in the front door. Not
sure if he will be met by any
side of security. Was there any
procedure that has to go on? No
one's really ever experienced
this before. And you saw all
that vote happened so quickly
there in the city hall. All
right, Ryan, go ahead. Catch up
with them. We'll get back to you
shortly. Jeff. While I still
have you did this and you seem
to suggest it did did this whole
procedure actually backfire on
Republicans that they
essentially give these two state
representatives and even bigger
platform and a much greater
following? I think they
absolutely did and really shined
a light on the fact that the
Tennessee legislature is one of
many bodies that simply has not
even debated or heard solutions
or discussions on guns. Yes in
the short term, without a doubt
, they have given a bigger
platform and also really shined
a light on the reality of racism
that still exists on the reality
of the essentially saying to
young activists that you don't
belong here. We're going to
handle things in our own way.
The speed in which this happened
this was just a few days. Zago
last week when they were
expelled. Of course they're
coming back in. But wolf what
we're seeing again as yet
another example of this urban
and rural divide this red and
blue divide in the country. So
for the politics of this not